[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه الساعه
الجديده ضمن تغطيه العربيه المستمره
للانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه 2022 نبدا
من ولايه فيلادلفيا التي قرر فيها مسؤولون
المدينه اجراء تعديل في اللوائح
الانتخابيه يقضي التدقيق في قوائم
الناخبين من اجل منع التصويت المزدوج
وتعني هذه الخطوه مقارنه قوائم الناخبين
الذين صوتوا من خلال البريد بقوائم
الناخبين الذين ادلوا باصواتهم في
الصناديق ومنشان هذا الاجراء ان يؤخر
الاعلان عن النتيجه النهائيه في هذه
الولايه وامنا فيلادلفيا الى الوزانه حيث
قال مسؤولون في الولايه انه تم نقل مركز
اقتراع في مدرسه بالقرب من مدينه نيو
اورلينز عاصمه الولايه الى مدرسه الاخرى
بعد تهديد بوجود قنبله التهديد تم توجيهه
ضد مدرسه
ديسكفري الواقعه على بعد حوالي 20 دقيقه
خارجه نيو اورلينز هذا هو دعى رئيس
الامريكي انصاره الديمقراطيين للاقتراع في
الانتخابات النصفيه مشيرا في تغريده نشرها
على حسابه في تويتر الى ان الديمقراطيين
قادرون على صنع التغيير في الانتخابات في
تغريده هي الثالثه خلال ساعات قليله جدد
دعوى انصاره للاقتراع واتهم الجمهوريين
بانهم يريدون اعاده الولايات المتحده الى
الوراء حسب تعبيره
هذا ويوصل الامريكيون التصويت في انتخابات
التجديد النصفي للكونجرس لكن متى يمكننا
معرفه اي حزب باتت بيده الاغلبيه بعد
اذلاء الناخبين باصواتهم اليوم قد يستغرق
انتظار النتائج ليله طويله وربما اياما
قبل ان يتضح ما اذا كان الجمهوريون او
الديمقراطيون هم من فازوا وسيطروا على
الكونغرس
ويتوقع كثيرون موجه ضخما من الدعم للحزب
الجمهوري و ضغطا كبيرا من الرئيس السابق
وهو ما يمكن ان يؤدي الى اعلان الجمهوريه
النصر بعد ساعات من اغلاقه صناديق
الاقتراع لكن مشاهدينا عده ولايات رئيسيه
مثل بنسلفانيا استبقت هذا الامر بالاعلان
عن ان فرزه كل بطاقه الاقتراع قد يستغرق
ايامك هناك مساله اخرى مشاهدينا وهي تصويت
عبر البريد بعض الولايات تفرز اصوات
البريد مبكرا قبل يوم الانتخابات ما قد
يرجح كفت حزب على اخر بينما ولايات اخرى
لو فرز هذه الاصوات الا في يوم الانتخابات
لذا قد تستغرق العمليه عده ايام في هذه
الولايه
هذه الانتخابات مشاهدينا هي استفتاء على
هذا الرجل على جو بايدن رغم انه قال انها
ليست استفتاء عليه بل استفتاء على
الديمقراطيه في امريكا لكن في النهايه
تبقى نتيجه الانتخابات كاشفه لراي
الامريكيين في اداره دبي ايضا اذا المزيد
في هذا العرض التفصيلي مع الزميل بركه
[موسيقى]
انا
الرئيس السادس والاربعون للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عمري 80 عاما قضيت منها 50 عاما
في السياسه ولم ازل
في عهد اصبحت فاتوره جره الغاز في مطابخ
المواطنين ولتر البنزين في سياراتهم
واضاءه غرف نوم تقض مضجعي تماما كما يفعله
لازم يفوت يوميا ليبقي عيني على الحقيبه
النوويه واصبعيه على الزناد
في خريف العمر الذي يصادف منتصف ولايه
الاولى اصل الى مكتب البيضاوي في الجناح
الغربي من البيت الابيض كل يوم لاجد كيف
راك ما طاقم ملفات البلاد الساخنه والعالم
الاكثر سخونه
وبعدما استكملت مواجهه كورونا وتداعيته
الاقتصاديه خفضت التضخم الذي لا يزال
مرتفعا واعدت البطاله الى مستوياتها ما
قبل كرونه واقريت مع الكونجرس قوانينا
بمئات مليارات دولارات لكل منها كقانون
رقائق الالكترونيه والعلوم قانون المناخ
والصحه خطه تحفيز الاقتصاد وخطته اعاده
بناء البنيه التحتيه
غير ان كثيرا من هذه القوانين لما تاتي
بعد ثمارا سريعه اقطفها في انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه التي ما فتات تعكر صفها
قضايا الاجهاض والمخدرات والسلاح المتفلد
والنظام الصحي وتلك الجندريه منها كذلك
صحيح انني كبرت وقد اتعثر على سلم طائره
وهو ما يتوسله دونالد ترامب سبيلا للهجوم
الانتخابيه عليه ولكني اظل الشغوف فاب
بقياده السيارات بسرعه جنونيه ولو كان في
شبابي صحيح انني كبرت وحصل ان اخطات مرارا
في خطاباته ونسيت اسماء وخالفت مراسم
واختلطت علي امور وهو مابات الجمهوريون
يعيرونني به ايضا وانا ابن المؤسسه
التشريعيه العريقه والشهير بالخطابه
والفصاحه وسن القوانين رغم مشكلتي ابتلعكم
عندي
يشار اليه عاده كفاني رئيس كاثوليكي بعد
جون كينيدي الذي اغتيل وكنائب رئيس لاول
رئيس اسود وكول رئيس تنوب عنهم امراه رغم
ما تسمعونه من اتهامات بمخالطات لصيقه
للنساء
وبين ملف محلي افرغ منه واخر دولي يبقى
عالقا تطفو على سطح ذاكرتي صور عائله
صغيره
زوجه الاولى ليليا وسوره ابنتي وهما
اللتان توفي في حادث سير بعيدا انتخابي في
مجلس الشيوخ وصوره بوم وهو ابن الذي خسر
معركته مع السرطان عندما كنت نائما للرئيس
وصوره هانتر نجل الاخر المتورط بسمعه سيئه
والاتهامات فساد في اوكرانيا
انا جو بايدن
نعم سيكتب التاريخ عن عهدي انني تسببت
بفوضه في افغانستان عندما سحبته ايفاء لهم
بوعودي ولكنه سيكتب ايضا انني قتلت ايمن
الظواهري دون ان ارسل له جنديا واحدا على
الارض واوروبا العجوز مثلي والتي انحدر
شخصيا منها
ليشمل فنلندا والسويد من اجل حمايتها بين
انني احكم في وقت يبزغ فجر اقطاب عالميه
رائده جديده عينها على ما تعتبره انها
القوميه قد تبدا بروسيا في اوكرانيا ولا
تنتهي بالصيني
دون الخالق والامر الواقع النووي ككوريا
الشماليه او الطامحه كائران والتي فشلت في
اعادتها الى الاتفاق النووي يقول للتاريخ
ان هذه الانتخابات النصفيه عاده ما تكون
استفتاء على الرئيس وماضيه ويقول للحاضر
انها قد تكون فتاه على الرئيس السابق
ومستقبله السياسي اما مستقبل السياسي انا
فربما لم يعد جنبني بالكثير انا
الذي تحدث عنه زميل طاهر بركه يدخل
الانتخابات النصفيه وهو يضع حزبه في موقف
صعب للغايه شعبيه الرجل اخذه في التاكل
والسبب الرئيسي في هذا يعود الى الاقتصاد
نقطه ضعفه الكبيره قبل الانتخابات انتقد
بيض قرار اوبك كلاس بخفض انتاج النفط ذلك
لانه حاول افضل افعال ليدخل الانتخابات
وهو بيده ورقه رابحه دون الالتفات الى
الحاجه الحقيقيه لسوق النفط ومصلحه
الاقتصاد العالمي كذالك
ازمه امريكا مع النفط بدات مع دخول
الجوبايدن المكتبه البيضاوي قرر الرئيس
السادس والاربعون وقفه منحي تراخيص
واذونات جديده للتنقيب عن النفط والغاز في
الاراضي الفيدراليه مشكله اولى من صنع يد
الرئيس فاقمها بمشكله ثانيه قرار بضرب
مشروع انابيب كيستون الاستراتيجي مع كندا
الذي يستطيع نقل تقريبا نحو مليون برميل
يوميا الى ساحل خليج الولايات المتحده
اوقفه كما اشرنا بيضا بعد ان اجازه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ضمن استراتيجيه
ادارته لتعزيز امن الطاقه في امريكا
اكثر من ذلك قاوم بعد الضغوط التي مارستها
كندا على الولايات المتحده لاحياء خط
انابيب كيستون اكس ال تعويضا عن الامدادات
الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبات لكن لمشكله
النفط في الولايات المتحده جانب وسبب مزمن
ايضا
ليست كلها من صنع اخطاء بيضا الذي يعرف
عنه اصلا توجه نحو الطاقات المتجدده
بموازاه استراتيجيه خفض الاستثمارات في
قطاع استخراج النفط وتكريره فالادارات
الامريكيه المتعاقبه في العقدين الماضيين
اهملت قضيه صيانه واستثمار مصافي تكرير
النفط
متلو بايدا يسر الديمقراطيون على
استراتيجيات تحديد سقف مرتفع لمواصفات
الوقود تتسبب بمشاكل في الامدادات وارتفاع
الاسعار بالطبع بالارقام ايضا تراجع عدد
المصافي 13 بالمئه خلال عشر سنوات رقم هو
الادنى
ارتفاع الاسعار في الولايات المتحده يعود
الى نقص القدره على تحويل النفط الى وقود
وبالتالي تراجع المعروض في السوق الداخليه
بالارقام شكل الهامش بين اسعار النفط
الخام والمنتجات المكرره نحو 20 دولارا
نقلتها الحرب الاوكرانيه الى عتبه السبعين
دولارات
عمل اخر يضع بثقله المعنوي العلاقه السيئه
بين بيض وشركات النفط الامريكيه
الجمهوريون يتهمون الرئيسه بالاضرار
بشركات النفط العملاقه واذ قال قدره
انتاجها بالضرائب المبالغ بها والقيود
القانونيه والتشريعيه اذا اضفنا الى سلسله
هذه المشاكل الداخليه عامل الطبيعه اعني
هنا الاعاصير التي تتسبب في التوقف مصافي
التكرير او تراجع قدرتيكر فيها ايضا يعود
انخفاض مخزون البنزين الى اغلاق المصافي
بحجه عدم ربحتها الكبيره لماذا لم تعد
مربحه بسبب القوانين البيئيه الصارمه
والضرائب كما اشعرنا فالمشكله اذا تقنيه
لكنها لماذا اخذت هذا البعض والسجال الذي
وصل الى حد اتهام قرار اوبك كلاس
لا يتحمل بيض مسؤوليه اسعار الطاقه وفق
بلوبرج هناك عوامل عده متعلقه به لعب
الدورا مهما خصوماته لشركات النفط وتعهده
بوقف استخدام الوقود الاحفوري ضمن مجموعه
من العوامل الاخرى طبعا افقدت قدره السوق
طاقه الامريكيه على التعامل بمرونه مع
صدمه الاسعار
مع امتحان انتخابين لولايته في الثامن من
نوفمبر
سلاح سياسي بوجه سلعه حيويه اقتصاديه بحث
ليس لامريكا فحسب بل للعلم
وفي لقاء مع العربيه اشارك سانتروم عضو
مجلس الشيوخ السابق عن ولايه بنسلفانيا
والجدل هو ما قد يخيم على العامين
المقبلين لفتره رئاسه جوبايدر
موسم الكرز
ونتابع مع شبكه مراسيل العربيه في هذه
الساعه من التغطيه من بنسلفانيا ومن
نيويورك ومن واشنطن العاصمه معنى مباشره
بيير غانم وطلال الحاج وكذلك ناديه
البلبيسي مرحبا بكم زملائي الاعزاء ناديه
العلي ابدا معك بشكل عام الان هل من
معطيات على حجم اقبال الامريكيين على
التصويت في هذه الانتخابات المصريه
بالدرجه الاولى يعني نعرف ان هناك 48
مليون امريكي صوتوا في انتخابات في تصويت
مبكر
والتوقعاتهم 140 مليون امريكي سيصوتون في
هذه الانتخابات وبالتالي الحديث منذ ايام
على انها غير مسبوقه بالنسبه للحماس
والاقبال ربما سيترجم على ارض الواقع
بالاقبال على صناديق الاقتراع في بعض
الولايات مثل همم نفاده وارزون واليات
الساحل الغربي كان هناك اقبال شديد همم
طبعا هذا يعتمد صناديق الاقتراع لم تغلق
حتى الان وعلى عكس الديمقراطيات الغربيه
يوم التصويت وليس بيوم اجازه يعني ليس
بيوم عطله وبالتالي بعض الامريكيين
ينتظرون انتهاء اعمالهم حتى يقوموا بعمليه
التصوير لكن الكثير من الامطار تتجه الى
الولايات الحاسمه والولايات الحاسمه مثل
البيانيه جورج
الديمقراطيه من عدمه
صفات بمجلس الشيوخ على الاقل
والمشاهدين طبعا كما ذكرت ناديه السباق
محموم بين الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطيسي
هذه الاربع ولايات بالتحديد الفرص يعني
تبدو متقاربه بين الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطيه في هذه الولايات كنسلفانيا
نيفادا وجورجيا واريزونا على ذكرها نذهب
اليك في الغانم انت في بنسلفانيا كيف هو
حجم الاقبال هناك وكذلك كيف هي المنافسه
بين مرشحي الحزبين في المنافسات المختلفه
كذلك
نحن الان في ساعات بعض الظهر من الملاحظ
ان هناك نسبه اقبال جيده ربما لن تتخطى
بنهايه اليوم 60 او 60% من مجموعه
الناخبين وصلنا الان اقله الى نسبه 35 الى
40% وبالتالي نحن لا نرى همم صفوف طويله
من الناخبين تقف عند ابواب اقلام على
اقتراع ولكن هناك نسبه مقبوله الى حد كبير
جدا اما بالنسبه للمنافسه بين المرشحين
خصوصا لمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي من المعروف
في من خلال الاستطلاعات ان التقارب شديد
بين المرشح الديمقراطي فلتر منه والمرشح
الجمهوري اوس هذا من نراه ايضا على الارض
هذه المنطقه حيث انا الان هرشي هي نموذجيه
لانه في المدن الكبيره
نسبه الديمقراطيين عاليه جدا ما بينهما
احمر ولكن هذا الامر ايضا يتغير هذه
المنطقه من هنا الى وصولا الى منطقه
هاريسبيرج العاصمه عاصمه بنسللنيا هناك
تصاعد لاعداد الديمقراطيين وتراجع لاعداد
الجمهوريين لذلك المنافسه كبيره والمنافسه
كبيره ايضا على شخصيتي المرشحين نعم ساعود
الى همم هاتين الشخصيتين وبتحديد شخصيه
محميه اوس كذلك في نفس البانيا بعد قليل
الافيال ولكن نذهب الى نيويورك هذه
المدينه العالميه والتي لها خصوصيه
امريكيه كذلك طلال همم انت مباشره من هناك
على مقربه
همم كيف هي عادات نيويوركين في التصويت
عاده في الانتخابات النصفيه وهل هناك
اختلاف في هذه العادات لدى سكان نيويورك
في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه 2022 طلال
عدد هما يقولون صهيب على هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه ولكن الاقبال اليوم لاحظته كان
كبيرا ربما لان هذه الولايه هي
الديمقراطيه بامتياز ولكن يشعرون بان هناك
التهديد
لقادتهم ديمقراطيه كما تعرف الانتماء
الحزبي والولاء الحزبي له اثره ايضا لذا
نرى كثير من
الديمقراطيين يتوجهون الى همم مراكز
اقتراع للتصويت للمرشحين ديمقراطين طبعا
من اهم همم المرشحين الديمقراطيين في هذه
الاونه
وهي الحاكمه حاكمه هذه الولايات التي كانت
مقدمه ب 20 او اكثر من 20 نقطه 20% من
الاصوات على
وهو المنافس الجمهوري وهو من مؤيدي ترامب
تعرف كيف ان هذه ولايه لا تحب او لا تميل
الى يا سات ترامب حتى انه اتخذ من ولايه
فلوريدا منزل له هو همم
طلال
فلوريدات هل تسمعون فقط
ولكن حتى بالرغم من عدم همم اهتمامه
بالنيول هذا الشخص وهو يهودي ومن من كبار
مؤيدين لاسرائيل في داخل المسجد همم
مجلس النواب الا انهم هنا الان هناك توجد
منافسه ده بين هذا الرجل همم
الموالي لترامب وسياساته
وان فينا له نتائج عام 2020
وهذا يعطيك فكره الى الى اي مدى هم غيره
سعيدين بالقياده الديمقراطيه في هذه
الولايه التي تعتبر معقل من معاقل
الديمقراطين
ومن نيويورك ديمقراطيه بامتياز في العاده
التقليديه طبعا نعود الى واشنطن العاصمه
وناديه هنا اسالك بالنسبه لنا كعرب
للمشاهد العربي ما الذي يهم همم السكان في
الشرق الاوسط او مواطنين الدول العربيه في
هذه الانتخابات النصفيه خاصه فيما يتعلق
اذا كان الكونغرس جمهوريا ام ديمقراطيا في
ظل اداره رئيس ديمقراطي ما الذي سيتغير
اذا تغيرت المعادله في الكونجرس في هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه على العالم العربي
والشرق الاوسط
تركيبه الكونجرس الجديد وخصوصا في مجلس
النواب اذا كانت هناك اغلبيه جمهوريه كما
تعرف من مهام الكونجرس هو همم يعني سن
القوانين تتعلق احيانا بتمويل مشاريع سواء
كانت حروب او صراعات او الاخيره لكن
بالنسبه مثلا ناخذ موضوع ايران كانت هناك
معارضه بالنسبه للجمهوريين من العوده الى
الاتفاق الذي وقع في عهد اداره ديمقراطيه
سابقه وهي اداره الرئيس اوباما حتى هذه
الاداره البيت الابيض لا يتحدث عن ربما
حتى عن اي امل او مساحه للتحرك بالنسبه
للعوده الى هذا الاتفاق لانه ايران تضع
شروط غير مقبوله بالنسبه للاداره وبالتالي
حتى لو كان هناك اتفاق لن يكون على شكل
معاهده يصادق عليها الكونجرس بالنسبه مثلا
لتصنيف الحوثيين على قوائم الارهاب يمكن
ان نرى دفع في هذا لكن الاداره لديها لا
تزال من خلال السلطات التنفيذيه لدى
الرئيس الكثير همم الادوات يمكن ان
يستخدمها خصوصا بالسياسه الخارجيه همم
التاثير سيكون في السياسه الداخليه
بالدرجه الاولى لي همم ربما منع الرئيس
بايرن من تمرير قوانين داخليه لانه
بالنهايه هذه مهام الكونجرس وخصوصا في
مجلس الشيوخ اذا سيطر عليه الجمهوريين
يمكن يمكن ان يمنعوا بعض التعيينات
بالنسبه للرئيس المصادقه على بعض
التعيينات المهمه سواء كانت في الاداره او
بالنسبه للسفراء لكن بشكل عام هو تحديد هو
تاثير محدود الى احد كبير
سلفانيا فيها سباق محمول
ولايه حاسمه كذلك ولكن فيها شيء لافتات
خاصه في السباق على مقاعد مجلس الشيوخ همم
المرشح محمد همم
وهو مرشح لحزب الجمهوري ويدعمه دونالد
ترامب ولكن محمد بالتركيه همم هي محمد
باللغه العربيه وهناك من يتساءل كيف يدعم
دونالد ترامب
مرشحا من اصل مسلم
حول رئيسا من الضروري القول ايضا ان
دونالد ترامب اختار شخصيات ومن بينها
ومحمد اوز لتكون مدعومه من قبله لانه لا
يريد ان يدعم شخصيات تاتي من تاريخ الحزب
الجمهوري اراد اشخاص يكونون مديونين
مدينين اكثر لدونالد ترامب من ان يكونوا
شخصيات سياسيه معتبره ومعروفه من قبل
الامريكي نعم طيب مادامنا نتحدث عن
الولايات الحاسمه اريزونا كذلك من
الولايات المهمه جدا في هذا السباق زملاء
الاعزاء والمشاهدين الكرام الان هذا الخبر
العاجل الظاهر على شاشتنا بدايه همم
التسريبات الان او النتائج الاوليه فوكس
نيوز تقول عن سلطات اريزون 20 بالمئه من
مراكز الاقتراع في الولايات تعاني من خلل
فني طبعا هذا حديث عن موضوع اخر المتعلق
بالمشاكل الفنيه المتعلقه بهذه الانتخابات
وكذلك من يروج كذلك لان هذه الانتخابات
ربما فيها مشاكل وهناك اتهامات بالتزوير
من قبل موريين وهمم من انصار ترامب كذلك
اذا لم تكن النتيجه على هواهم اذا فوكس
نيوز تتحدث عن ان 20% من المراكز الاقتراع
في الولايه تعاني من خلل فني نتحدث عن
اريزونا نقلا عن فوكس نيوز بير اعلم انه
الخبر عاجل ولكن هل هناك لديك اي معطيات
يمكن ان تشرح لنا بها المزيد حول ااه ما
المقصود بالخلل الفني هنا في همم ارينا
عاده ما يحدث في افلام الاختراع هو ان
الناخب يضع اللائحه طويله ويشطب الاسماء
التي يريدها ثم يضع هذه الورقه على اله
همم
هذه الاله تاخذ التصويت والتحتفظ ايضا
بالورقه في اغلب على اوقات تكون المشكله
هي في هذه
المرحله الالكترونيه ولكن هذا لا يعني ان
عمليه الانتخاب سوف تتوقف بل ما يحدث هو
ان همم اقلام على الاقتراع سوف تقبل
الاوراق وتحسبها وهذا سوف يؤخر عمليه
الفرز فقط ولكن لن يؤخر عمليه الانتقاليه
همم طلال اعود اليك في نيويورك كما كنا
نتحدث نيويورك بالعاده هي تصوت لصلاح
الديمقراطيين وكذلك بالعاده درجه العاده
انه الامريكي من اصل عربي هم يصوتون لصالح
الديمقراطين اكثر من الجمهوريين ولكن في
ظل اداره ايه جو بايدن يعني هناك مشاكل
اقتصاديه كبيره يعاني منها الامريكيون
جميعا ماذا نعرف عن الامريكي من اصل عربي
واذا كانوا يعني سيعاقبون هم ايضا بيضا
على ادائه فيما يتعلق بغلاء المعيشه في
امريكا
اعتقد
ان الامور
بشكل كبير
للحزب
الديمقراطينا في اغلبيتهم في اغلبيتهم ولا
تحدث هنا عن اصحاب المتاجر او اصحاب
الاعمال الجمهوريين عاده همم في اغلبيتهم
سوف يصلون الحزب الديمقراطي همم مساله
الاقتصاد تمصه كل الناس على كل المستويات
سواء كنت تاجرا او فقيرا همم 51% من
الناخبين هناك يعتبرها القضيه الاولى
والاهم والاساسيه لذلك الديمقراطين خلي
يقول تاتي مساله حق الاجهاض وهي في ولايه
كان يوم مساله مهمه جدا للمراه
هذه الولايه على النساء لتقديم الاصوات
لصالحها من اجل الفوز بها بمنصبها وعلى
السوق وعلى الجلي السوداء
الافريقيه همم
المكافحه الجريمه وسلامه المواطنين تاتي
في المرتبه الثالثه وان كانت مهمه جدا
ويعتمد عليها المرشح
لزود منافس كاترينا الحاكم الدولي لكسب
الاصوات طيب عود في عجاله فقط الى ناديه
همم كمان نتابع مشاهدينا في العاجل نقلا
عن اعلام امريكي توقعات بتاخر نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه في كاليفورنيا بسبب
التصويت عبر البريد النادي هنا اعود اليك
في عجاله يعني يبدو ان هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه فيها الكثير من المشاكل لماذا
لا لا لا نقول كثير من المشاكل هي متوقعه
على فكره ولا احد كان يرى بان نتائج ستعلن
الليله و ستحسم الليله على الاقل في مجلس
الشيوخ اولا في جورجيا مثلا اذا لم يحصل
المرشحين على نسبه اكثر من 50% سيكون هناك
تلقائيا جوله ثانيه هذه
ستكون في شهر ديسمبر عادى على انه
تنسلفانيا اعاده تماما بالنسبه لبن
سلفانيا
يمكن ان اتحدث باسهاب لكن انه يفكر بان
الرئيس
الفنيه بسبب العدد ثلاثه ايام وايضا
بالنسبه لها الان الكاليفورنيا هو شيء
متوقع يعني نحن نتحدث عن 50 ولايه نتحدث
عن عدد غير مسبوق 140 مليون امريكي
المتوقع اني ان يصوتوا في هذا الانتخابات
لذا لا نريد ان نبالغ في عدد في في الشكل
او حجم المشاكل لكن نريد ان نقول باننا قد
لا نتوقع ان نتائج النهائيه يعني هذه
الانتخابات الليله لا احد يتوقع ذلك
ما في مجلس النواب اسهل لانه التوقعات هي
فقط على خمس مقاعد ومن السهوله ان يعلن
عنها في مكان ما في ولايه ما لكن بالنسبه
لمجلس الشيوخ توقع الا تكون النتيجه
الليله
والصناديق الاقتراع باقي لها يعني همم هي
عند السابعه على ما اعتقد بتوقيت الامريكي
همم منتصف الليل بتوقيت جرينتش صحيح ناديه
يعني
حوالي ثلاث ساعات
يا نعم الساحل الغربي ثلاث ساعات ثلاث
ساعات اكثر طبعا ست ساعات فيه الساحل
الغربي لذا ليلى طويله ههه
زملائي الاعزاء من نيويورك واشنطن العاصمه
يا طلال الحاج ناديه البي سي وافي
ومشاهدين هذا فصل قصير نستكمل بعد وادي
الساعه ضمن تغطيهنا المستمر من العربيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم اعزائي المشاهدين مستمرين معكم
في تغطيه وقائع هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه نفى المتحدث باسم البنت رايدر
التقارير الاولانيه وزير الدفاع الامريكي
بعد انتخابات التجديد وصفي وهكذا رائد
رائع يواصل تاديه مهامه كلب
ابراهيم ابراهيم
معنى مباشره من واشنطن امال مدلل يستفيره
السابقه في الامم المتحده مرحبا بك معنا
استاذ امال في العربيه لماذا هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه مهمه
ومفصليه للبنات المتحده الامريكيه لانها
ستحدد الاتجاه الذي تسلكه الولايات
المتحده بعد سنتين من اداره الرئيس بعيده
فهذه الانتخابات تاتي بعد الذي حدث بعد
الهجوم الذي حدث على الكونغرس وتاتي ايضا
بعد ارتفاع الاسعار وتضخم في البيت
المتحده وانخفاض
انخفاض شعبيه الرئيس وهذه كلها امور تؤثر
يعني انه هذه الانتخابات المصريه لدرجه
العاده في تاريخ هذه الانتخابات الامريكيه
انه يكون دائما فيه عقاب للرئيس بشكل او
باخر يعني نادرا ما كانت نتيجه الانتخابات
النصفيه نفس الساكن في البيت الابيض نفس
الحزب يكون يحصل على تقدم في في الكونغرس
بسبب انه الامريكيين همم يرون النتائج همم
مقام به الرئيس طوال سنتين هل هذه المره
مختلفه لانه جو بايدن وترام في المشهد
في السنوات الاخيره من اصل 22 انتخابات
هناك 20 انتخابات جرى فيها تغيير
التغيير في الانتخابات الحزب الذي لديه
اغلبيه بعد الانتخابات
وحزب الرئيس عاده يخسر هذه الانتخابات هذه
المره الوضع يعني اكثر حده لان بسبب ليس
فقط بسبب همم في البيت الابيض ولكن بسبب
ان الرئيس السابق ترامب وضع حوالي مرشح
يدعمونه همم ومرشحين في جميع انحاء
الولايات المتحده ولا جميعا يرفضون نتائج
انتخابات 2020 وهناك تخوف لانه اذا فازه
هؤلاء في الانتخابات لن يقبلوا بنتيجه
الانتخابات مهما كانت اذا فازوا في
الانتخابات يقبلون النتيجه واذا خسر
الانتخابات فسيقولون نعم
طبعا طبعا وهذا خطر على امريكا ولكن هذا
شيء خطير جدا يعني انه نتحدث عن همم اكبر
الديمقراطيات وام الديمقراطيات في العالم
همم الولايات المتحده يكون فيها طرف او
اطراف تتحدث عن تصوير الانتخابات يعني
ماذا تركوا للديمقراطيه الناشئه
طبعا وهذا هو الذي يقوله الرئيس
يقول الديمقراطيه الامريكيه في حد ذاتها
هي في خطر وهناك همم بعد المحللين الذين
يقولون ربما انتخابات هذه السنه او
انتخابات 2020 تكون اخر انتخابات
ديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده هناك تخوف
جدي على الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده
اذا كان هناك همم مسؤولون امريكيون سيتم
انتخابهم ويكونون في الكونغرس ويكونون في
الولايات في المراكز الاسلحه الحساسه ولا
يقبلون نتائج الانتخابات
الامريكيه وهذا يؤثر ايضا على على صوره
امريكا في العالم وعلى دورها كائده في
موضوع الديمقراطيه في العالم
يعني ناخذ وجهه النظر الاخرى هل معقول
يعني انه نحن نتحدث عن شخصيات كبيره في
الحزب الجمهوري يتحدثون عن تزوير في
الانتخابات معقول ان يتحدثوا من فراغ يعني
ليست لديهم ادله ليست لديهم همم شواهد على
هذا الكلام لانهم يعني مسؤولون سيحاسبون
عنها هكذا
يعني احكام همم قويه
حتى الان لم نرى اي همم
اثباتات او دلائل حسيه وجديه همم في همم
الذي يقوله الذين يدعون الانتخابات 2020
جراء تزويرها ولو كان هناك اي اثباتات
صدقني كنا رايناها في همم الكونجرس في
الاعلام في كل ال- ال- الدوائر الامريكيه
التي عاده تقوم بمراقبه هذه الامور لحتى
الان لم نرى اي شيء من هذا القبيل نعم نعم
اليك ما المهم في هذه الانتخابات من
القضايا الداخليه برايك وربما الحزب
الديمقراطي هو يدفع فاتوره فيها اهم
القضايا الداخليه التي تؤثر على الناخب
الامريكي
القضيه الاساسيه هنا في الانتخابات قديتين
القضيه الاقتصاديه وال 77 في المئه من
الامريكيين يقولون اقتصاد هو السبب
الاساسي الذي سيدافعهم الى تصويت لطرفنا
الاخر او لحزبنا الاخر ولكن مساله
الديمقراطيه ومساله حمايه الديمقراطيه
وحمايه النظام الامريكي والحفاظ على
نزاهته هي اهم قضيه الان ااه مطروحه وهي
يقول الرئيس
هذا صحيح ولكن المشكله بالنسبه
تتحدث عند مقاطع همم امريكا العادي لا
تهمه الموضوع مثل ما يهمها الموضوع
لقمه عيشهم اكثر من تصويت لموضوع الديمقرا
ولكن هي اساس هي الموضوع اساسي جدا وهو
سيحدد مستقبل الولايات المتحده
عفوا همم الاسبوع المقبل الرئيس سيكون في
قمه ال 20
واذا خسر الانتخابات سيقلل سيده ضعف هذا
موقفه ومن موقف الولايات المتحده في
العالم عندما يقف امامهم اذا كان
الجمهوريون ربحوا وهم يقولون ان انه ان
الانتخابات مزوره شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المدخله الشقه امال مدلل يا سفير السابقه
في الامم المتحده كنت معنا من واشنطن
العاصمه
مشاهدينا هيكليه البيت التشريعي في
الولايات المتحده تفرض نفسها على تفاصيل
الحياه السياسيه لا تتداخل كثيرا ففيما
يعد نائب الرئيس الامريكي رئيسا لمجلس
الشيوخ هو الثاني في خط الخلافه للوصول
للمنصب الاول اي رئاسه البلاد وقد شهد
تاريخ الولايات المتحده بالفعل الحالات
عند مماثله اعقبت استقالات رؤساء او
اغتيال
كمان يوتيوب
مجلس الشيوخ الواجب الدستوريه الوحيد
لنائب رئيس الولايات المتحده الصفه
السوريه لان صوته صامت لحين الحاجه لكسر
تعادل الاصوات طالما ان مجلس الشيوخ لديه
رئيس مؤقت ينتخبوا من اعضائه ويمتلك
الصلاحيات المرافقه للمنصب لكن نائب
الرئيس يقف ثانيا في خط الوصول الى سده
الحكماء في حال وفاه رئيس البلاد او
استقالته
فعقب اغتيال الرئيس ابرام لينكين عام
1865 خلفه نائبه الديمقراطي اندروجين
ليصبح الرئيس الامريكي السابعه عشر غير ان
خلافات الجنس مع الكونغرس بسبب انتهاكه
لصلاحيات منصبه او صلاه الى بدء اجراءات
سحب الثقه منه في العام نفسه قرار لم يمر
بمجلس الشيوخ بفارق صوت واحد وحافظ على
منصبه لحين نهايه
بعدها ب 100 عام تقريبا شغل سبيرو اغنيو
منصب نائب الرئيس تحت قياده ريتشارد
نيكسون فصول الفساد اغرقت اغنيو الذي اجبر
على الاستقاله عام 73 ما دفع بالرئيس
نيكسون الى تعيين الجيرالد فورد نائبا
للرئيس بموجب احكام التعديل الدستوريه لكن
في العام التالي اوقفت فضيحه
نفسه الذي استقال قبل بدء اجراء عدله
10 10
[تصفيق]
مجلس النواب او الشيوخ الا انها اقتربت
منها احيانا فرائس مجلس النواب قال البرت
وقف مرتين في الترتيب التالي للرئاسه بعد
استقالتي اغنيو ونكسون لكن تعيين فورد
نائبا للرئيس ثم صعوده مباشره الى مكان
نيكسون دون انتخابات في المرتين ابعد
الفرضيه
ونتابع مباشره من واشنطن العاصمه مع
الدكتور وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه دكتور وليد اهلا بك
معنا في هذه
التغطيه ما يشغل المواطن العربي انعكاس
هذه الانتخابات الامريكيه على قضايانا
خاصه القريبه من هناك يعني قضايا متعلقه
بايران احياء الملف النووي كذلك التوتر مع
الصين الحرب في اوكرانيا وانعكاساتها
علينا الاقتصاديه كذلك ما الذي سيغره همم
ان يكون الكونغرس احمر او ازرق جمهوري او
ديموقراطي في هذه الانتخابات منعكسه على
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
استظاهر لو بدانا اولا بالسؤال الاول على
بالورق يعني الدستوريه ماذا بامكان اي
كونجرسون انتخاب ان يؤثر على السياسه
الخارجيه هذا يعني اول على الصعيد النظري
الكونجرس يؤثر على امران مجلس النواب يؤثر
على الميزانيات الميزانيات يعني بامكانه
ان يضغط على الاداره ان يوفر لها او ان لا
يوفر لها الميزانيات هذه قدرته اما مجلس
الشيوخ فله قدره ان يعين السفراء الوزراء
يثبتهم اذا للكونغرس قدره ان يؤثر على
الاداره حتى ولو كانت هذه الاداره من حزب
الاخر ولكن اداره او تنظيم السياسه
الخارجيه يبقى هذا الموضوع بين يدي
الاداره الفارق الوحيد انه اذا كان البيت
الابيض له اكثر في الكونجرس هو مرتاح هو
يتخذ القرارات والمعارضه للحزب الاخر داخل
الكونغ رسلان تؤثر كما حدث في السنتين
الماضيه اذا تمكن الجمهوريون من السيطره
حتى على واحده من الهيئتان واذا سيطروا
على الاثنين يكون الموضوع اكثر ثقلا عندها
بامكانهم ان يضغطوا على السياسه الخارجيه
ولكن ليس بامكانهم ان يغيروها يعني قد
تكون هنالك بعض المفاوضات مساله اقرار
المساعدات لاوكرانيا مثلا الم تتغير اذا
كانت الاغلبيه الجمهوريين في الكونجرس
لن تتغير بشكل دراماتيكي لانه الجمهوريين
في جزء منهم يريد الاستمرار في دعم همم
اوكرانيا مثلا اكبر مركز همم فكري لهم هذه
التاج له نفس المشروع ولكن ينتقدون همم
اذا طريقه الايذاء لهذه الاداره ولكن
هنالك الصعود بين هذه القاعده الجديده
التي هي تنتج الاكثريه جديده للجمهوريين
ويؤثر عليها رئيس ترامب هي لا تريد
الانغماس في القضايا الخارجيه لا تريد ان
يدفع همم دافعه ضرائب الامريكي كثيرانه
اذا سيكون هنالك توازن بين نستمر في
مساعده اوكراني ولكن لا نقوم بهذا العمل
الكبير
دكتور وليد هناك من يقول ان الجمهوريين
اذا استعدوا الاغلبيه في الكونجرس
فسيبداون في اجراءات انتقاميه ضد الرئيس
الديمقراطي منها التحقيق في اعمال ابنه
هانتر همم وهناك من يتحدث ربما حتى الذهب
بعيدا الى اجراءات لعزل الرئيس هل هذه
شعارات انتخابيه فقط ام يمكن ان نتوقع ان
تحصل بالفعل
هي اكيد شعارات انتخابيه دون شك يعبئون
كما عبئ الديمقراطيون عندما كانهم في
المعارضه ولكن جزء من هذه التهديدات سوف
يتم تنفيذها ونحن يعني على الصعيد التحليل
كنا قد حذرنا منذ الصيف 20 انه اذا وصل
الانقسام بشكل عمودي الى العمل يعني لن
تتمكن الهيئات الاداريه او الادارات في
الولاده الامريكيه من العمل بشكل سليم
لانه الكل في كل سنتين سوف تاتي اكثريه
جديده وتحاول معاقبه الاكثريه الاخرى ما
كنت اود ان اقوله في كل هذه النقاشات ليس
هنالك فريق هو الام تريزا يعني عنده عفاف
وجيد جدا والفريق الاخر هو الشياطين
الاثنين سوف يحاولوا معاقبه بعضهم البعض
نعم الحديث عن التزوير مره اخرى في هذه
الانتخابات دكتور وليد كيف تراه
هنالك التزوير الصغير وهنالك التزوير
القومي الكبير نحن كنا معتدين في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على الاقل منذ انتهاء
الحرب البارده انه تكون هنالك عمليات اما
تاخير اما تزوير اكبر حادث قدر رايناه في
العام 2000 في بوم بيتش وبرور في في ولايه
فلوريدا وقد اخرت التعداد لانتخاب رئيس
والى ما هنالك وكما قال المحللون من قبل
هذا امر معتاد الان التزوير يصب في عمليه
اتهام الاخر بانه وراء التزوير اما
المعارضه تتهم الحكم الحكومه اما الحكومه
تتهم المعارضه وهذا امر جديد وخطير دكتور
وليد في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه شكرا
جزيلا لك منه العاصمه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اذا هذه الساعه انتهت ولكن
الترقيه مستمره للعربيه لهذه الانتخابات
النصفيه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
باقي حوالي ثلاث ساعات على اغلاق
الساعه في موجزه للانباء وبعده والتغطيه
في ساعه جديده مع زميله راويه الخاصه
[موسيقى]